[Música]
y nos comunicamos en directo bajo
nuestro corresponsal en medida mediante
niveles y sobre el resultado de las
primarias demócratas de cara a las
elecciones de noviembre charlie crist un
congresista demócrata de 66 años que en
el pasado fue republicano y que bajo los
conservadores él gobernó el estado hace
más de una década ahora será el oponente
del actual líder ron de santis en las
elecciones de noviembre anthony buenas
noches para usted un saludo y cómo se
llegó a este resultado además que dijo
la otra precandidata
bueno muy buenas noches ángel
efectivamente charlie crist ya es
oficialmente el candidato demócrata para
las elecciones de la cooperación de
florida con más del 59 por ciento de los
votos frente al 35 por ciento de su
contrincante nick y fred en estas
elecciones primarias hay que recordar
que charlie crist a partía como claro
favorito en estas elecciones primarias
aquí en florida a pesar de que ha sido
una contienda muy muy muy muy reñida en
los últimos días de hecho ambos
candidatos han estado aquí en el sur de
la florida tratando de promover el voto
de las minorías especialmente de los
afroamericanos
tratando también de poder
y arañar algunos de estos votos para
poder ganar con cierta seguridad
finalmente ha sido así como charlie
crist con más del 59 por ciento de los
votos ha ganado estas elecciones
primarias hay que recordar que nick y
fred que es actualmente la comisionada
de agricultura de florida ha criticado
duramente a su contrincante diciendo y
recordando que charlie crist tiene ideas
republicanas teniendo en cuenta además
que desde 2007 a 2011 él fue gobernador
de florida por el partido republicano y
así las cosas anthony como se presenta
ahora la contienda por la gobernación ya
con estos dos candidatos definidos
pues sí la verdad es que ahora se espera
una contienda aún más reñida entre
charlie crist y el actual gobernador de
florida donde santi es lo que se espera
ahora es que charlie crist pueda también
movilizar tanto el voto demócrata como
también el voto de los republicanos son
más moderados y que no se pueden sentir
a gusto con la línea dura de la política
de ron de sant y es que en los últimos
tiempos ha estado promoviendo políticas
pues como la ley antiaborto también la
ley antiinmigrante o incluso esas
polémicas medidas para prohibir hablar
sobre identidad sexual en las escuelas
pero también estas elecciones aquí en
florida deben servir también para
analizar de qué pasará de aquí a dos
años y florida acaba siendo un estado
péndulo o si finalmente acaba
reafirmándose por un estado
completamente republicano como lo vimos
dos años en estas elecciones
presidenciales